elizabeth warren had a proposal for
putting a certain percentage of workers
on corporate boards right
look he's going hey hey we're going to
put we're going to put employees on
corporate boards
that creates a disparity and then you
say we're going to create we're going to
fix it by putting people on corporate
boards
then you have to answer why the
billionaire class hates you they don't
time for a bonus installment of change
my mind for those unfamiliar these are
unedited conversations with an
opportunity to rationalize
one's own position now in a prior
episode on gun control i sat down with
this gentleman here george
and it discussed why common sense gun
control is actually nonsense if you want
to hear that conversation click the link
below now we uh just went into an
impromptu conversation
on so-called libertarian socialism it
was interesting and this is what changed
my mind is all about
without further ado here's george i'm
going to talk about libertarian
socialism
with george because i think look i want
to hear
the last time i really went through this
was uh was a
college and then about a year ago really
okay well in college when they described
it and are you know anarcho-syndicated
socialism and that's where you go right
you go to the catski like
catalina right and you get to them i
don't know i'm actually just reading
homage to catalonia by orwell you should
read it if you have it i have
oh you have yeah and i always find it
very interesting was it was it catalonia
existed was it from uh
was it from 38 or did it stop in 30
years it was only about four years
um it was only about four years before
they were taken over by the soviets yeah
but um
i mean they just got raped by the
soviets yeah and so i wouldn't say a
very good examination
yeah franco did and so much the fastest
the soviets were the real problems for
the catalonians i mean
but okay go ahead and explain it right
yeah okay i appreciate this i appreciate
it
and i also appreciate we i think this is
a good uh time where we can have a
dialogue like this even though i wildly
will disagree with you let you know that
thing
but no one accused the other person of
racism sexism homophobia like look you
believe in this that's fine
yeah let me hear it i mean like like i
said i'm on the left but i'm also
not like an identity politics kind of
leftist okay
yeah all right so you have no home right
now
politically you're almost there's a home
it's just not the leftism you see on
twitter
it's just not what you see okay so
explain to me what you mean by that that
you're a libertarian socialist
okay so what i mean is the way i see
libertarian socialism is i see it as
democratization of the economic sphere
right so we've had
democracization of the political sphere
right we had that with like the
enlightenment
to liberalism liberal democracies that
that's what we have today
democratization of the economic sphere i
see
as workers controlling their pursuits in
their work
controlling their workplaces having a
say
in decisions uh within their
corporations in the places they work
instead of a very rigid hierarchical
top-down system where you have
a board you have the c-suite you know
commanding orders from the top down
i think that if you work at a place like
say amazon
you should have an equal say in the
operations of that company
as jeff bezos does or as
you know anyone else does because i mean
you all
work for this entity you know so a
couple of things
um first off i'm not a big fan of amazon
but
let me ask you this really uh yeah no
let me ask you let me ask you this
um how do you juxtapose that with the
idea of libertarianism which is the
right of the individual because
you just said that a worker is actually
entrusting liberty to the individual
well what about the liberty of the
individual who invested all of that
money
and risk and resources into creating the
company only to not be able to reap the
rewards
right how is it justified to take that
by force
which is always what happens with
socialism from jeff
his faces yeah well i mean like he
his workers are the people that provide
the labor the fruits of amazon
are because of his workers i would
disagree really
which well he started amazon there are
no workers without them
do you really believe that the labor of
for example putting a postage stamp is
the same as someone who invested
millions potentially billions of dollars
lost in their own savings
right invested in a company built it
from the ground up do you really think
that they should be compensated the same
i'm not saying that there should be
equal wages
i feel like that's that's something that
is
so far like from a socialist perspective
something so
far in the future it's not really even
worth discussing right now
what i think i think it is important
because i need to know your end game
oh like what is yeah i need to know in
your in your idea sort of and i think
that you're
i don't think i'm characterizing you and
that this is sort of a utopia which we
know will never happen
um but what would that look like because
as a business owner
i would never have started my i employ
15 people and by the way i pay
significantly more than 15 an hour what
i think i would have never started it if
i thought that i would have
the same amount of sales because that is
a lot of sunk
costs that you put it into starting
something right i made no money for half
a decade i understand that
but the way i see it or
the way i think companies should be
moving in the future is towards
like a worker co-op type of model right
a model where
you know they're like there's true
democracy in the workplace you have
workers discussing
all right what is our company's
operations going to look like
for this like what are we doing with x
like everyone gets to say in it because
everyone is affected by it right
like if you are involved in a system and
you have no say or no choice in how that
system operates
or how it um yeah literally just how it
operates then
i mean that seems well let me ask you
this so um
because you just use the example of a
system so if i may i'd like to go with
sort of your algorithm
um do you believe that every person
who uses the system of ios or uses a
system of
microsoft do you believe that they're
just do you believe that they are just
as
no no it's not do you believe that
they're just as qualified in determining
how that system should work as a person
who created the system
no because if you're a consumer of ios
you're not involved
in the like the facilitation of it like
you're not so
let me ask you this and let me scale it
back a little bit i was using your
analogy of the system
do you believe that people who work on
the lower levels at apple
on the floor for example putting
together iphones
or people with people with white boards
do you believe that
they should have i think i know where
you're at they're just as capable of
your specialization of labor expertise i
totally understand that
i'm not saying totally disregard things
like expertise like if you have
say apple you have very specialized
employees working on a very specialized
product that they're selling right
it wouldn't make sense for someone like
a janitor working at apple in order to
be able to like
deliberate house something like that so
then who determines which person's
opinion is
involved in the process that's my thing
is like
because it's the same thing so you mean
all the workers workers
so the workers would vote yes do you not
think that the janitors would vote for
themselves to be specialized engineers
well i mean i don't think that's exactly
how it would work it's hard to speculate
as well how something like that would
work with
um like apple like i don't think it
would i don't think there's no i'm just
asking like why would
you don't think the janitor would say
like oh yeah i want to do that job why
would they vote against themselves my
point is as a business owner i have
people who work for
15 people work for my business i am so
grateful that not all of them have a say
in every decision that's made because
many of them have no idea and many of
them would not want the responsibility
of difficulty
i'm not even saying completely disregard
expertise when it comes to making
decisions that require that expertise
and specialization right okay
but i feel like but how do you enforce
it let's say the workers vote
okay so in a free society a libertarian
society
the workers vote the business owner says
no
well i mean in that theoretical society
there would be no owner mm-hmm
like all these workers would be equal
prices so then how do the businesses get
created and started
like i said like worker co-ops like i
feel like we should eventually move
towards a system in which
you have worker owned cooperation so how
do you displace the current owners and
turn it into co-ops right
at some point bernie sanders actually
bernie sanders and elizabeth warren
actually had
um they kind of had a plan on this not
exactly to the extent that i would
envision it but
the same elizabeth warren who went after
the gamestop bettors and defended wall
street that's the thing i'm not i know
i know that you were pissed you must
have been pissed about that right not
i'm not a fan of elizabeth warren i'll
tell you that but all right common
ground
but um they both proposed like hey
like we need work representation on the
board right
on boards of these companies like
workers who work on these floors of
these companies
workers who are doing a brunt of the
amount of work
that provides uh like what you love
about amazon is the fact that it's so
efficient
is that they get you your ship in one
day right like the fact that
they're very efficient in doing what
they do but that comes
at the expense of these workers that
comes at
the expense of um i mean like
so well i don't i don't agree with your
premise that workers are doing the brunt
of it and i think that anyone
and there's look and here's the thing
here's what's interesting to me can i
can i finish can i make a point here
what's interesting to me is for example
if you look at the increase in corporate
tax rates okay
supported by amazon supported by all the
big companies you look at the lockdowns
supported by all the big companies right
we've created more and this is
bernie supported lockdowns elizabeth
warren supported lockdowns socialists
supported lockdowns
they're the party of big business let me
explain to you why there are no more no
let me explain to you why
we have created more billionaires this
last year do you realize that than ever
no billionaires have gotten insanely
rich
but only this last year and there have
been more middle-sized businesses
and small size businesses that have been
shuttered than ever before
now guess what those mid-sized
businesses
oppose the higher corporate taxes oppose
the democratic socialism the only people
who support it are google amazon apple
facebook twitter youtube they support
your ideas
but people like me who employ 15 to 50
people are again you say they support my
ideas and yet
i want democratization of the workplace
they definitely don't support that well
guess who's going to have the ability to
get a waiver just like obamacare the big
companies
so we'll have to demo democratize my
workplace but they won't do that at
amazon
i mean do we just do you disagree with
me that there are elites who have more
influence in lobbyists for amazon than
me with my little youtube channel that's
just that's just how this country
operates
right like and i just influence of like
effective oligarchs
and do you see like big tech companies
like jeff bezos of the world and it's
interesting that we're sort of
we went from the bureaucrat phase to the
oligarch phase to invoke sort of
orwell right which is where we are at
this point where almost
conservatives now here's one thing where
i think we can find common ground
because a lot of people say like will
you sound like a socialist to me
but let me explain to you why where i go
look you have
five companies the wealthiest people
increase their net worth by 600 billion
in six months in this pandemic right
insane insane we agree that that's
terrible right do we both agree like
that's absolutely
now we probably it's morally
reprehensible same thing that all these
billionaires are created when small
businesses are suffering
now here's where we differ okay i think
it's reprehensible
not if they made their money honestly i
couldn't care less if they if amazon
made that money
i think it's impossible my point is if
they made the money because i chose
their goods or services
voluntarily i don't have a problem the
reason they made that money
is because of elizabeth warren's and
bernie sanders and bidens and kamal
harris's
who shut down the economy and determined
winners and losers in other words
i was precluded from going to a local
grocer i couldn't go to the local coffee
shop
in michigan i couldn't go to the local
nursery but i could go to costco and i
could order from amazon
i totally agree with everything you just
said but our difference comes with the
solution
right i don't believe that more
government would make it better i think
more government has made it worse i
think that government keeping these
businesses afloat is not only good i
think they had a moral obligation to do
so but they didn't keep businesses
afloat
no exactly that's they only gave money
to their wealthy donor class
and the worst offender is bernie and
elizabeth exactly you have all these big
companies i mean it reminds me of 2008
in terms of bailouts going to big banks
right right like you have all these
major companies who are benefiting from
this and then the middleman
like the small guy gets cut out right
they want to privatize profits and
socialize losses big banks
exactly yeah sound like a socialist now
but my issue is
guess what what if no company is too big
to fail
that's a self it's a self-solving
problem if you say we're not giving you
money
if you say well we're not shutting down
businesses guess what in every single
one of those scenarios
more government is not required to fix
it government created that problem
government created subprime loans
government decided to bail out thanks my
view is government is sustaining that
problem and government
completely has the power to eradicate
that issue like when it comes to
coronavirus pandemic right
in terms of businesses failing like what
half of small businesses are
never going to reopen right yeah it was
something like the last number so was 60
of businesses that were open in april
would be closed by october
and like record profits for costco a lot
of those closures would be
indefinite right yes my problem is
the government had the resources and the
opportunity to keep them afloat
via stimulus checks by uh um
like all the funding that they actually
didn't have enough though that's also
the issue
i definitely they don't have enough
money really okay
they don't they first sold two problems
they don't have enough money and
the money didn't go to the people who
needed it exactly that's like the money
went to social
this is where you talk about how you're
not an identity politic person yeah the
money went to things like critical race
there went to a bunch of
[ __ ] earmarked projects the money
and not to mention the policy
favorite giant corporations that had to
be such an
insignificant amount of money that went
to little
no you know joe biden's infrastructure
bill let's use his right now two
trillion two plus trillion
billion dollars how much if it goes to
infrastructure um i actually don't know
i haven't read this
less than 600 million really yeah so
what's the rest on
[ __ ] i'm just talking about 35
billion here 200 billion there
big part of it is for green new deal
stuff not necessarily energy
infrastructure no not just
infrastructure but proposing certain
policies
okay 600 million 600 billion dollars to
infrastructure
my point is it's a never-ending whole
right for example if throwing more money
if the government had money throwing
more money
at schools washington d seemed to trip
one of the best schools in the country
we don't have a money problem we have a
spending problem and we have a
corruption problem with the government
which i think we agree with
definitely yeah no i just don't think
that we should put more power in the
hands of the corrupt
i think that you're believing that
inherently there are some people some
people who are altruistic what i'm
saying is
probably the examples of people you
would pick most bernie
and elizabeth warren bernie every single
step of the way if you
do research right i'm sure you have but
if you look at his policies
ended up benefiting even i'm not saying
he meant to ended up benefiting amazon
costco walmart and then you had
elizabeth warren come out against the
gamestop bettors
but my problem is bernie is one he's one
socialist senator
in a c of what 535 federal i know can
you imagine how bad it would be if
everyone was burning there would only be
amazon
stew that's my point right people like
me were going oh don't shut down my
business and barney's like
shut down the business i mean but did he
not support
um more government funds going to middle
school
but the point is businesses business
owners like just don't shut down my
business
but you can't fix the problem by giving
look giving me 600
is not going to play 15 people no that's
not even like not even stimulus i mean
like
like at that point we were in a pandemic
like we've had what
over 500 000 people die like i feel like
it's a very reasonable fear to have in
order for us to be
i don't think that it's reasonable to
create the worst unemployment economic
devastation
increasing suicide rates shut down
schools over a virus with over
99 survivors definitely had a bad effect
obviously but
like there's like there's a public
health thing and i mean we could get
into like fouchy and always flip
positions on
i mean right now in the united states
people should not be walking around
with masks you're sure of it because
people are listening really no
closely to this right now people should
not be white there's no reason to be
walking around with a mask
i mean for me as a public health
official obviously
i would like the consideration that
everybody wears a mask
if you have a physical covering with one
layer you put another layer on it just
makes common sense
see i think we would have a lot of
common ground yeah i thought she's kind
of a dick
is that can we end up with he's kind of
a dick he yeah he's kind of been touted
as like the know all when it comes to
health and pandemics and he's but you're
like is it
last week or this week he's very
noticeably switched position so it's
hard
but the point is and then she will never
lose power under a socialist
government do you understand that people
like him never lose power
fauci has suckled at the government t
forever he screwed up if you look at the
response to aids
fauci has been a charlotte he hasn't
seen a patient in 40
years that's kind of crazy yeah think
about that and the doctors who have seen
patients have been banned from youtube
saying well i don't think this is the
right solution i think fauci is wrong
and then two weeks later he goes and he
agrees with him so my point is i think
we're so close
but fauci bernie biden elizabeth warren
these are career politicians and they
don't care about you
or me there's plenty more to get to but
i want to let you know that none of
these episodes take place without your
support and especially now that the
entire channel
has been demonetized indefinitely
consider going to crowdershop.com
get yourself some slick threads uh we've
got some cool new designs dropping soon
thank you so much for the support no
foreign caliphate we're funded by
viewers like you
actually on with the show i don't know i
think i feel like bernie has been
that one guy that has been speaking up
for
working people for poor people i think
he's
speaking almost every step of the way i
think i mean it's very
it's very like verifiable like you can
go back to his history you can go back
to literally the 1980s
and he's saying the exact same things
he's saying now that's such a marked
change from every other politician in
washington right now
like i agree he's been consistently
wrong
in my opinion but i do agree with him no
but here's that i think he's genuine
he's definitely i don't think he's i
don't think he's genuine as far as like
i don't think he's genuine as far as
like he's personally very not generous
if you look at the way he tips and his
charitable
contributions so i always i'm always
leery of someone who wants to spend
someone else's money
and never their own i think it's
spending other people's money i feel
like it's
but i do believe that he i do agree with
you he's been consistently socialist now
i would ask you one thing before you go
so you said and i agree with you you can
consistently look at his
policy you can consistently look at his
positions i should say um because if i'm
not mistaken wasn't he a mayor
and then he was a state senator and then
he was a senator
i'm not mistaken i feel like he's he he
was at the house at some point i think
he was at the house maybe his house and
then senator
yeah okay um but if you look at his
proposed policies and what he has
supported through this pandemic
it has his types of policies let's say
everyone voted in the house right i'm
just a bill
house senate 100 agreed on the policies
that bernie supported
you would only be left with the
trillionaire class and then afterwards
you would say tax them more
but the point is at that point the
damage is done i don't know i just oh
shutting down businesses get rid of the
game stop bettors
right this is it's just to me i go okay
i think his heart may be in the right
place but pragmatically speaking
it always ends up destroying people i
don't know i feel like he just
definitely has been speaking for common
people
and back to uh i was going to say
something about warren and vernon and
then
we do have to go but i appreciate it
yeah thank you um no for sure
um him and elizabeth warren had a
proposal for
putting a certain percentage of workers
on corporate boards right
i feel like that's something that is
like a market change that we can
slowly move towards a more democratized
workplace now do you okay
but let me i understand what you're
saying but here's the point right it's
like the guy's
the guy's palming it do you know do you
understand what that term means right
with magicians when they're palming
something look
look he's going hey hey we're gonna put
we're gonna put employees on corporate
boards okay meanwhile you know what
you know what creates more of a
disparity of power shutting down
middle-sized businesses and small
businesses
but then you have to tripling them with
taxes then you have to that creates a
disparity and then you say we're going
to create
we're going to fix it by putting people
on corporate boards how about ukraine
you have to answer why the billionaire
class hates him why they're so
they don't amazon supports the increase
in
the increase in corporate i'll give you
maybe the most perfect illustration of
this
during the democratic primary you had
after he won nevada
this was before south carolina well
let's hold on let's use national
elections primaries are different
because primaries are betting on who's
going to win the primary it's
it just goes to show like the views of
the billionaire class right
yeah who overwhelmingly supported
democrats not republicans
no it's not even close okay fair enough
but
i feel like they do that for optics
reasons there's definitely an incentive
for them to see
exactly exactly right that's why i'm not
into the whole identity
or i would also argue the reason they do
it is because these giant corporations
know they can incur
a 30 corporate tax and they can incur
all kinds of red tape legislation
and come out unscathed whereas small
businesses can
i mean definitely i i definitely feel
like there is
a tornado warning i feel like it's an
ambrose oh it's an amber alert
i just forgot what we were talking i
know damn amber i don't know
it's serious no one should we're not
joking about hamburg we're not shaping
about
no um no i look look okay i believe your
point go in our class
can i say i really enjoyed our
conversation thank you thank you what's
up um
what you had after nevada before south
carolina
you had establishment democrats who were
panicking
all of the ones that were backed by
billionaires yes all of the ones that
were backed by muddied interests
they were panicking because the
democrats
so what happened you had pete buddha
judge shop out of the race right you had
amy klobuchar drop out of the race right
and in return i mean like pete is now
the head of the department of uh what
transportation like these are
like they i agree with you coalesced
against him in that moment because
money interests see him as a threat can
i ask you something
when you say they coalesced i want to
make sure we agree you mean corporate
donors
and the other democrats right yes that's
exactly what okay
my point is apply that to a national
level corporate donors
still coalesce with other democrats and
that's my concern what they did what
they did to bernie
they'll do to us but my whole point is
the fact that they
want like they're so fearful of
coalescing
around someone like bernie because he
poses such a direct threat to their
interests
i think what why is it i think what
poses a direction which is why i think
he's genuinely a man
of like working common class people like
he's never worked so oh he was a
carpenter like he's happy he's never had
full-time gainful employment now
since college no no no we haven't this
guy has not
not in 40 years but let me tell you this
let me i understand where you're coming
from but let me say this
i mean i agree with you but there's a
slight difference though let me tell you
where there's a slight difference
the difference is i do think you were
right that they were afraid of bernie
becoming the nominee
now the reason why is because they knew
that when you looked at those polls
bernie was imminently beatable
and they wanted to have a democrat in
power i feel like that's definitely a
point they definitely
thought that he would be a loser
candidate right but and they want to
make sure that their democratic bidders
do it for them for sure so it's not that
they oppose bernie it's that they want
to but the point is after a national
election then we have to go
primaries we have to go to the national
election overwhelmingly
why do you think amazon and google and
facebook
why do you think all the biggest
companies overwhelmingly support
democrats and seemingly anti-corporate
policies
i mean in terms of optics i mean the
country is
sort of moving towards i feel like we're
in a sort of anti-core produce i guess
you could say
why do you think big banks back
democrats um
i mean i don't know they both like they
back both like it's not even solely a
democrat
they've been consistently banking but
it's definitely part of like an optics
thing in terms of identity politics like
it's definitely
like i remember there's a well i think i
think there's a component of that i also
think that they stand to benefit
financially off the backs of us
yeah and i mean i don't know like i
remember a wells fargo ad about
recognizing the lgbt community and i'm
like all right you don't give a [ __ ]
about the lgbt community like you're
saying something like someone walking
like you suck you can't open a checking
account
no i'm sorry that doesn't offend you
definitely like
it's not even anti-gay just a joke no um
see i can get along better with a with a
socialist libertarian than i can with a
white woman [ __ ]
talk to more libertarians i feel like
that's let me ask you this
as a black guy okay is there anything
more annoying than white woke feminists
who speak for you
i mean we've been through a few of them
today like well i think like really i
haven't seen that and they're like
and i'm like black people don't feel
that way yeah i mean i i do hate white
people
speaking on my behalf for sure
like the black community is seen as a
monolith by both republicans and
democrats which is a problem to me
like we are expected to have a uniform
view of seeing the world which i mean if
you actually talk and
i would say by black people too
sometimes yeah it's
like it's been let me say one thing that
i feel really empathetic and
we do have to go okay but i will say
this one thing and he you know quarter
black pair is my producer
he's uh he's funny we didn't realize he
was black for like his dad is really
black what is he him he's black
his dad is like biracial but looks black
but then he just looks totally white it
does look like there's a bit of ethan
again
he looks like he might be like mexican
so for we only found out when we asked
him like can you what does that mean in
english in spanish he's like why do you
think
what do you think he's like dude i'm
black we were like what this is after
six months
but um what was i saying before this i
totally forgot
oh here's one thing i will say because
he's an example too you know if you look
at a lot of his relatives and his
cousins and his dad
you know they look more black than he
does um but
one thing that i do look at with young
black men today and i go oh man i didn't
have to deal with that as a white guy
is for example we have fans who watch
the show and like
one example comes to mind he was like a
black kid who was like a metal head
and he was like oh yeah my black friend
say i'm not black no yeah it's because
you're expecting i go you know as a
white person no one ever tells me like
you have to like this it's like oh he
likes country or he likes hip hop oh he
likes this kind of food
and that's not pressure exerted from
white people but it is something that's
from both spheres honestly because like
yeah because that sucks
i would imagine that's like that's not a
systemic oppression but it is these
expectations like of a black kid feeling
from other black kids that he's not
black enough for sure and i mean like
i've experienced that like
growing up like it happens but
definitely something that i
i never could change and i feel like
it's constantly reinforced to the point
where
i don't know if it'll change anytime
soon especially with white woke
i think he's been reinforcing it i think
especially with republicans to be honest
oh come on now
no i we were leaving it on a good note
there's definitely a way republican you
really feel like i'm pigeonholing you
more than a white woke feminist
i don't think you believe that i mean
certainly your party is more directed
against
the interests of the average black
person than a democrat so even if a
white woke feminist is
spouting her [ __ ] saying she knows
that you're talking to me you're talking
to a person here
you're you're an anarcho so you're a
libertarian socialist
and i am you said you're the left i'm to
the right of attila the hun okay
i am not a fan of republicans i
actually didn't know that i like donald
i liked donald trump
in a lot of ways uh there are some
republicans that i like but i've been
pretty pissed off with a lot of
republicans and they're
they're cow towing to the tech tech
oligarchy
how do you square support with donald
trump for his
i don't okay well i hate to keep saying
we have to go his support
of that system we were both just
criticizing well donald trump has
resulted in the lowest
african-american unemployment out of any
republican and there are more black
americans who voted for donald trump
than any other republican in recent
memory yes it is
it absolutely was you know what happened
i think freedom for all is freedom the
best
is best for all here's the thing i as a
libertarian socialist i agree i believe
in freedom but
oh no you don't i don't you don't you
believe in taking over companies from
people and establishing a company board
that's not freedom
that's not no that's totalitarianism i
believe in workers having a say
in their companies and i believe in
businesses being able to own that that
is
true economic freedom to me not no
that's not the definition
but here's okay here's one thing i think
we can both agree on
free speech is absolute absolutely yeah
and certainly
right now you would have to agree that
the democrats oppose that more than any
other political party is
definitely a trend of censorship which
is concerning but
i mean the thing about free speech that
makes me so sad about that is that with
such a left
a leftist ideal a leftist value the fact
that you hear other people's points
because it it's just derived directly
from like
enlightenment liberal thought yeah well
there was a girl here who got really mad
at me earlier who brought up like huck
finn
that it used the n-word in the book she
goes and we shouldn't have i think she
wasn't playing we shouldn't have it in
audiobooks
and i said what she goes well if you
were reading it in the class would you
say the n word is well yeah if i was
reading the class and i'm reading a book
if i'm reading a book and we're all in
the class reading it and uh
she was wildly offended you know richard
pryor his album um
richard pryor's really interesting comic
he's the best comic ever he's definitely
up there he's definitely up there and he
said i don't want white people to call
it one crazy n-word he's like why would
you change the name of my album
i love him i love chappelle i love yeah
i don't
you know andrew schultz i do know i
don't know him personally but i am
familiar with him
it's funny everyone that you mentioned
you know i go prior murphy chappelle
i just don't find chris rock funny and
had someone say that's racist i go look
come on i just said prayer is one of my
favorite ever
ever patrice o'neal obviously harlan oh
yeah george cronkite george columbia
bill burr i mean the point is if you're
funny you're funny
yeah trevor noah's painfully unfounded i
want to throw him out of the window
we're being honest
george carlin was an anarchist george
carlin became a grumpy old man but
george carlin certainly wouldn't
really agree with youtube in the seven
do you think george carlin will be fine
with this right now if i say this word
it's removed from any and all social
media we'll bleep it
george carlin would say oh if you say
that word they remove you from
everything that's bull
i mean he would say that's [ __ ] i
like i think it's disrespectful to
people to say it i don't think i was
referring to a car
all right but i do have to listen i
appreciate it bro george thank you so
much thank you
i think we disagreed a lot but i think
we did this is exactly what
yeah i wasn't even planning on talking
about this but i appreciate it actually
very glad we got to talk about it
thank you man i appreciate it thank you
so much
[Applause]
oh no now i've got to pee again there
you have it in time for you to sound off
in the comments
below is libertarian socialism a thing
did you learn about that in in college
how do you think they juxtapose with one
another
and do you think socialism in general
can ever work and as always
comment which topics you would like to
see covered most in the future
appreciate it i love most of you because
i have to
bye well you're still here on the
internet that's a that's a miracle this
is long and there are no
cats playing piano or
midgets on tricycles but uh look there
are other change my mind videos you can
click here there's some
new ones coming up and if you want to
support the show look you you guys all
know about mug club but
you can get some of these fight like
hell shirts at crowdershop.com that's
the best way to support us
also if you know
someone in qatar
with oil money my number's not hard to
find